hello hello again so moving forward I'll
be assuming that you have a visual
understanding of linear transformations
and how they're represented with
matrices the way that I've been talking
about in the last few videos if you
think about a couple of these linear
transformations
you might notice how some of them seem
to stretch spaced out while others
squish it on in one thing that turns out
to be pretty useful for understanding
one of these transformations is to
measure exactly how much it stretches or
squishes things more specifically to
measure the factor by which the area of
a given region increases or decreases
for example look at the matrix with
columns three zero and zero two it
scales i hat by a factor of three and
scales J hat by a factor of two now if
we focus our attention on the 1x1 square
whose bottom sits on I hat and whose
left side sits on J hat after the
transformation this turns into a two by
three rectangle since this region
started out with area one and ended up
with area six we can say the linear
transformation has scaled its area by a
factor of six compare that to a shear
whose matrix has columns 1 0 and 1 1
meaning I hat stays in place and J hat
moves over to 1 1 that same unit squared
determined by I hat and J hat gets
slanted and turned into a parallelogram
but the area of that parallelogram is
still 1 since its base and height each
continue to have length 1 so even though
this transformation smushes things about
it seems to leave areas unchanged at
least in the case of that 1 unit square
actually though if you know how much the
area of that one single unit square
changes it can tell you how the area of
any possible region in space changes for
starters notice that whatever happens to
one square in the grid has to happen to
any other square in the grid no matter
the size this follows from the fact that
grid lines remain parallel and evenly
spaced then any shape that's not a grid
square can be approximated by grid
squares pretty well with arbitrarily
good approximations if you use small
enough grid squares so since the areas
of all those tiny grid squares are being
scaled by some single amount the
area of the blob as a whole will also be
scaled by that same single amount this
very special scaling factor the factor
by which a linear transformation changes
any area is called the determinant of
that transformation
I'll show how to compute the determinant
of a transformation using its matrix
later on in this video but understanding
what it represents is trust me much more
important than the computation for
example the determinant of a
transformation would be 3 if that
transformation increases the area of a
region by a factor of 3 the determinant
of a transformation would be 1/2 if it
squishes down all areas by a factor of
1/2
and the determinant of a 2d
transformation is zero if it squishes
all of space onto a line or even onto a
single point since then the area of any
region would become zero that last
example will prove to be pretty
important it means that checking if the
determinant of a given matrix is zero
will give a way of computing whether or
not the transformation associated with
that matrix squishes everything into a
smaller dimension you'll see in the next
few videos why this is even a useful
thing to think about but for now I just
want to lay down all of the visual
intuition which in and of itself is a
beautiful thing to think about okay I
need to confess that what I've said so
far is not quite right the full concept
of the determinant allows for negative
values but what would the idea of
scaling an area by a negative amount
even mean this has to do with the idea
of orientation for example notice how
this transformation gives the sensation
of flipping space over if you are
thinking of 2d space as a sheet of paper
a transformation like that one seems to
turn over that sheet onto the other side
any transformations that do this are
said to invert the orientation of space
another way to think about it is in
terms of I hat and J hat notice that in
their starting positions J hat is to the
left of I hat if after a transformation
J hat is now on the right of I hat the
orientation of space has been inverted
whenever this happens whenever the
orientation of space is inverted the
determinant will be negative the
absolute value of the determinant though
still tells you the factor by which
areas have been scaled for example the
matrix with columns 1 1 & 2 negative 1
encodes a transformation that has
determinant I'll just tell you negative
3 and what this means is that space gets
flipped over and areas are scaled by a
factor of 3 so why would this idea of a
negative area scaling factor be a
natural way to describe orientation
flipping think about the series of
transformations you get by slowly
letting I hat get closer and closer to J
hat as I hat gets closer all of the
areas in space are getting squished more
and more meaning the determinant
approaches 0
once I hat lines up perfectly with J hat
the determinant is 0 then if I hat
continues the way that it was going
doesn't it kind of feel natural for the
determinant to keep decreasing into the
negative numbers
so that's the understanding of
determinants in two dimensions what do
you think it should mean for three
dimensions it also tells you how much a
transformation scales things but this
time it tells you how much volumes get
scaled
just as in two-dimensions where this is
easiest to think about by focusing on
one particular square with an area one
and watching only what happens to it in
three dimensions it helps to focus your
attention on the specific one by one by
one cube whose edges are resting on the
basis vectors I hat J hat and K hat
after the transformation that cube might
get warped into some kind of slant a
slanty cube this shape by the way has
the best name ever parallelepiped a name
that's made even more delightful when
your professor has a nice thick Russian
accent since this cube starts out with a
volume of 1 and the determinant gives
the factor by which any volume is scaled
you can think of the determinant simply
as being the volume of that
parallelepiped that the cube turns into
a determinant of 0 would mean that all
of space is squished on to something
with zero volume meaning either a flat
plane aline or in the most extreme case
on to a single point those of you who
watch chapter two will recognize this as
meaning that the columns of the matrix
are linearly dependent can you see why
what about negative determinants what
should that mean for three dimensions
one way to describe orientation in 3d is
with the right hand rule point the
forefinger of your right hand in the
direction of I hat stick out your middle
finger in the direction of J hat and
notice how when you point your thumb up
it's in the direction of K hat
if you can still do that after the
transformation orientation has not
changed and the determinant is positive
otherwise if after the transformation it
only makes sense to do that with your
left hand orientation has been flipped
and the determinant is negative
so if you haven't seen it before you're
probably wondering by now how do you
actually compute the determinant for a
2x2 matrix with entries ABCD the formula
is a times D minus B times C here's part
of an intuition for where this formula
comes from let's say that the terms B
and C both happen to be 0 then the term
a tells you how much I hat is stretched
in the X direction and the term D tells
you how much J hat is stretched in the Y
direction so since those other terms are
0 it should make sense that a times D
gives the area of the rectangle that our
favorite unit square turns into kind of
like the 3 0 0 2 example from earlier
even if only one of B or C are zero
you'll have a parallelogram with a base
a and a height D so the area should
still be a times D loosely speaking if
both B and C are nonzero
then that B times C term tells you how
much this parallelogram is stretched or
squished in the diagonal direction for
those of you hungry for a more precise
description of this B times C term
here's a helpful diagram if you'd like
to pause and ponder now if you feel like
computing determinants by hand is
something that you need to know the only
way to get it down is to just practice
it with a few there's really not that
much I can say you're animate that's
going to drill in the computation this
is all triple e true for
three-dimensional determinants there is
a formula and if you feel like that's
something you need to know
you should practice with a few matrices
or you know go watch Sal Khan work
through a few honestly though I don't
think that those computations fall
within the essence of linear algebra but
I definitely think that understanding
what the determinant represents falls
within that essence here's kind of a fun
question to think about before the next
video if you multiply two matrices
together the determinant of the
resulting matrix is the same as the
product of the determinants of the
original two matrices if you try to
justify this with numbers it would take
a really long time but see if you can
explain why this makes sense in just one
sentence
you
next up I'll be relating the idea of
linear transformations covered so far to
one of the areas where linear algebra is
most useful linear systems of equations
see you then
you